Okay.
So you've got a time-line in place.
And, now it's time for you to follow it.
And this might seem a little asinine,
but
trust me,
it's a great learning experience.
Even if your actual time to completion
is way off from your estimate, you'll
still have a better idea as a developer
how long it takes you to do things.
There are great time-tracking apps,
like Toggl, for instance,
that help you keep track of how long
it takes you to complete a given task.
There's a link to Toggl
in the instructor notes,
if you want to check it out.
But maybe it's not your cup of tea,
and you have some other methods for
tracking your time.
If you do, please share those thoughts
on the forums, because both myself and
your classmates would really
like to hear about them.